[Music]
uh now larry your life has changed a lot
um
go ahead go ahead
you're a terrible man uh
your life has changed a lot of years you
are you are single now and i was
wondering you're out there you're dating
do you ever worry that that women uh
will be maybe more attracted to your
fame than for who you really are as a
person you know what i'm saying do you
do is that a concern of yours
what are you nuts
why would that concern why would i care
[Laughter]
what are they supposed to like me from
me yeah is that the idea well that was
the they had many many years to like me
for me
and that
that that didn't happen didn't go so
well that didn't there was no liking for
me really and there shouldn't have been
really there's not that much to like
actually
i
[Laughter]
so
no don't like me for whatever you want
to like me for right now right yeah so
so it doesn't bother you if they say oh
that guy he's famous he's rich i want to
go be with that you don't kill me no be
with me yeah
i'm doing things yeah
that's good that's a good thing that's a
good thing in fact
if a woman now said to me
i'd just say if a woman now said to me i
just want to be with you for who you are
i think get out of here
i said i don't want that no no you got
this is all making money you got the
wrong guy
go go find a nice dentist yeah
uh now uh did you before you were famous
did you date a lot were you were you out
there playing the field a lot you know
my problem is that i was very i was very
particular
yeah and which is that because i was
just very desperate at the time
so it's an odd kind of combination to be
desperate and in particular yes
and
you'll find that you'll notice that a
lot of desperate people are very
particular like even like like quasimodo
okay quasimodo quasimodo very particular
the the the hunchback punch
had to have the best looking girl in the
village
you know and and his friends would try
and fix them up they'd go quasi
there's a there's a very nice girl in my
office so a wonderful personality i i
want to introduce you to her
is she good looking
[Laughter]
she's a good looking fuzzy
you're a monster
idiot you're the ugliest man in power
isn't she good-looking what are you
talking about you have to be
good-looking
so you know i i was particular